- So, well, your new job,
I hear that you're hosting the Oscars,
this is amazing!
(audience applauding)
With Wanda,
Wanda Sykes, Amy Schumer?
- And Amy Schumer
Yeah.
That's amazing.
- Yeah. There they are!
- So great.
- I am so excited about this,
'cause one, I don't
think there's ever been
like three women to host like the Oscars.
I don't think that's ever happened.
- No. it's never happened.
- And you're all three really funny,
I'm so excited about it.
Are you nervous about it?
'Cause here I've had to host something
and I had to trick people
because when they asked
me to host, I was like,
"I'm not a comedian, I'm not like you,
"like I can't do that."
So, I decided to sing
because I thought I
could get away with it,
'cause I'm like, "Well that's my thing."
- Maybe I should do that.
Maybe I
- Exactly.
get that lady from the nursing home,
back in that audience.
(chuckling)
- Oh my God!
- Shut her up.
But are you nervous about it?
'Cause I know that people
like to rip on people,
people like to have a
good time with people.
- I mean, yeah.
I think you can not be a little nervous
'cause you want it to move,
you want people to enjoy themselves.
And although...
I mean, I am with two standup comedians.
So, you know I-
- But you are very
funny, you're all funny.
- Thank you.
- Yeah.
Thank you.
- That's what I'm saying.
I expect you to rip a little.
No, but I want y'all to
do that a little bit.
- Yes.
No, we will.
- Like for fun, it's fun.
- I hate when people get mad,
like all you celebrities that get mad,
you know what?
Your lives are awesome,
let us poke fun at you.
We wanna poke fun at us.
- Yes.
(audience applauding)
- Like it's fun.
- It's true.
March 27th will be.
- We know you're human,
but March 27th, just show up ready.
Just show up ready.
That's all I'm saying, it's okay.